question here about creatine moving on
from uh
an alpha betty white is a username
uh
would removing creatine before and or
during a watercut be advisable
how big of a strength loss should i
expect and in what time frame
assuming that i'm a responder to
creatine
so i would not bother removing creatine
in the context of a water cut
first of all to do it you'd have to do
it ahead of time so the washout period
some people say four weeks some people
say you know closer to six or eight
weeks depending on how confident you
want to be but we're talking about a
month or two of going without creatine
to get it fully washed out from your
system and so like when you're reviewing
a study on creatine uh if there's a
washout period it better be at least
four to eight weeks otherwise there's
going to be some residual
elevations of creatine stored in muscle
and other tissues um so i don't know if
it's really worth it to like if you're
someone who actually gets benefits from
creatine and you're a responder i'm not
sure that you want to go you know
two maybe even three months without the
creatine leading up to an event where i
assume you're hoping to optimize your
performance and another thing to keep in
mind
is that you can still very much
dehydrate yourself when you're on
creatine so the creatine will increase
your kind of baseline total body water
level but that doesn't mean that you're
going to be unable to then reduce body
water like you can absolutely dehydrate
yourself to your heart's content despite
the fact that you're on creatine uh your
heart may or may not be contented with
it exactly so once once it's pumping
blood through your [ __ ] arteries that
looks like molasses yes um so you can
dehydrate to your heart's discontent
regardless of creatine supplementation
and i will say my bias here is that i'm
just generally not very fond of water
cuts if i'm being honest
of course i understand there are certain
uh
there are certain situations where you
accept the health related trade-offs uh
for the performance-related benefits i
do think that there are many athletic
endeavors where people think they're
getting a performance benefit from their
water cut but they're actually harming
their performance depending on the
timing of the cut and the timing between
weigh-in and actual competition but
that's probably a conversation for
another day but
no i i don't think there's much utility
in removing creatine uh before a water
cut uh depending on the situation if i
were coaching you i'd probably maybe try
to talk you out of the water cut
especially if it's a very aggressive or
extreme one but nonetheless the creatine
is not going to be a critically
important factor there